[Music]
what kind of curve is uniquely defined
by these two points
a line
how about three points
a circle
this basic geometry is ancient history
Euclid proved it more than two thousand
years ago in his seminal math treaties
elements
now try to figure out the shape of a
curve that passes through a million
points in a thousand dimensions and is
super twisty what would that look like
although daunting finding a solution to
this problem is fundamental to probing
deeper principles of math and the
solution also holds the potential to
improve digital data storage the
security of your crypto wallet and the
privacy of electronic communications
it's called the interpolation problem
and two young mathematicians Eric Larson
and Isabel vote of Brown University have
solved it the interpolation problem
asks if you fix some general collection
of points when is there a curve of some
specified type through those points in
search of answers the pair chipped away
at the problem for years we started out
tackling cases in small dimensional
spaces to try to get our hands dirt
Y and then I think around 2019 or so we
came up with a good idea that we thought
might help us solve the whole problem
along the way their collaboration took
on a whole new dimension well we got
married in 2017.
much of the groundwork for a potential
solution was laid out 150 years ago by
German mathematicians Alexander Von
Brill and Max nother before you could
ask what properties does a given type of
curve have
you need to first answer the question of
what types of curves are there the
theorem predicts what types of Curves
can exist based on three properties the
first is dimension you can think about a
curve in actual physical space that
would be a three-dimensional space
um but we don't constrain ourselves to
two Dimensions or three dimensions the
second quantity is the degree of a curve
so you should think uh here like how um
twisty
or wobbly
the curve is the third is the genus or
number of holes a curve has curves
themselves
um have a sort of topological properties
but if you were to look at the solutions
over the complex numbers then it's going
to look like something that's
two-dimensional so it could look like a
sphere
or it could look like the surface of a
donut or it could look like the surface
of a
two-hole donut in general it can have
any number of holes
it wasn't until the 1980s that modern
math offered a proof of Brill Nether and
this opened doors to the interpolation
problem Larson and vode were determined
to solve the problem for all possible
types of Curves we had to come up with
three different ways of breaking the
curve into simpler curves so we take
some curve it's complicated it's very
wobbly
so we take this wobbly curve and we
break it in three different ways by
breaking down the complex curve in
multiple steps Larson and vote were able
to get something simple enough that they
could attack it with their bare hands we
knew how slippery it was how you really
had to to work hard to to get everything
to to match up Larson and votes proof
confirmed the interpolation problem in
all cases showing that curves will
always interpolate through the expected
number of points with only four
exceptions which they also explained the
couple's proof is a powerful tool for
exploring a whole new class of ideas a
bit of a surprise to you finally finally
completed you know it's
we've just been thinking oh this is what
I do is I work on this problem but then
you're like wow it's done
more than 2 000 years ago the Greek
mathematician zenadoris argued that a
sphere is the optimal shape of a single
bubble
this may seem obvious but it took until
the late 19th century to prove it
mathematically
what about a cluster of multiple bubbles
researchers study bubbles to both better
understand their geometric properties
and potentially improve everything from
computer algorithms and biological cell
models to firefighting foams
for decades mathematicians have sought
the optimal configuration of larger
bubble clusters but it turns out the
solution is one of the hardest problems
in Geometry
the bubble problem can be stated simply
what configuration of bubbles encloses a
given number of volumes while minimizing
surface area and the key point is that
the surfaces are allowed like if if I
smash my bubbles together I'm allowed to
save on the surface that's between them
I mean it's an optimization problem and
that's such a universal kind of problem
with all kinds of applications from our
own experience of blowing bubbles we
know that larger clusters of bubbles
tend to form tight clumps rather than a
long chain but how can we know whether
these formations are actually optimal
in the 1990s John Sullivan now of the
Technical University of Berlin formed a
guiding conjecture he described what we
now call a standard bubble or a standard
bubble cluster there's fears they meet
120 degree angles they all touch there
could be lots of different ways to
achieve that
it turns out that that's not the case
Sullivan's conjecture States if the
number of volumes you want to enclose is
at most one greater than the dimension
there's one cluster configuration that's
the best there's basically one way to
achieve this and his conjecture was that
this way is the optimal way to visualize
Sullivan's optimal cluster Place Four
Points equidistant on a sphere
inflate the points into bubbles or discs
on the surface until they bump into each
other
keep inflating them until the entire
sphere is covered we end up with a
symmetric cluster that all touch and
meet at 120 degree angles now place the
sphere on a flat plane add a light at
the North Pole to cast a two-dimensional
shadow of three bubbles rolling the
sphere around creates clusters of
Sullivan's Shadow bubbles that can
enclose any three areas
by 2002 mathematicians had proved
Sullivan's conjecture for the double
bubble and at this point some speculated
another hundred years would pass before
approved for three bubbles could be
found but then Emmanuel Millman of
technion University and Joe Neiman of
the University of Texas Austin entered
the picture so what we were working on
was sort of the probabilistic version of
this problem
and we were interested actually
originally we were just we would have
been happy to do double bubble at the
beginning but we're like you know we
have to come up with something new
right and so we came up with some new
things after some success solving the
analogous probabilistic bubble problem
the pair hit a snag transferring their
new techniques to the geometric one so
we were stuck on this for a long time
and definitely a breakthrough came when
we actually we kind of gave up to be
honest
Millman and Neiman realized that if you
give bubbles one extra dimension of
space you get a bonus the best bubble
cluster will have mirror symmetry across
a Central Plain we were like okay
let's give up on what we were trying to
do and see what we can get from the
Symmetry and then as soon as we have
that symmetry that you know that
symmetry combined with what we had been
working on for the previous three years
all of a sudden like then we were able
to move on from there but Millman and
Neiman's proof of Sullivan's conjecture
for triple bubbles in dimensions three
and up is not the end of the story we're
stuck at a maximum of five levels right
now but I feel like it's just like a
tiny little thing that we are not seeing
and then that that problem will go away
foreign
[Music]
take a set of points and start randomly
connecting them with lines
at what point will an interesting
pattern emerge
like a triangle
or a hamiltonian cycle a chain of lines
that passes through each point exactly
once
in a branch of math called combinatorics
graphs like these are valuable tools for
probing the inner workings of complex
systems a graph is just another name for
a network networks are everywhere like
Facebook Network or you can think about
traffic Network you know obviously
networks and things like that
but real life networks can be huge and
hard to study so mathematicians use
random graphs to model their properties
in the random graph Theory finding
thresholds is a central subject people
worked on finding threshold for each of
interesting properties
interesting properties can emerge as you
increase the density of lines in a
random graph the sudden moment of Change
Is defined by a threshold in nature
thresholds are responsible for abrupt
Transformations and the emergence of
complex patterns but it turns out that
determining threshold is extremely
difficult
instead mathematicians use a method to
arrive at a ballpark figure they have a
very natural lower bound to the
threshold that we call the expectation
threshold the expectation threshold
turns out to be much easier to estimate
or determine
in 2006 mathematicians Jeff Khan and Gil
kalai posed their expectation threshold
conjecture it states that the gap
between the expectation threshold and
the real threshold is at most a
logarithmic Factor but sometimes smaller
or even non-existent the concili
conjecture just gives one simple
solution to find out the location of the
threshold for many many interesting
properties so it's just so powerful and
it's it was hard to believe that this
conjecture is true
that was until two mathematicians at
Stanford Jin Young Park and Hui fam
stumbled onto an elegant six-page
solution after a long sleepless night it
really came about by really not working
or aiming directly at the Khan kalai
conjecture it was a surprise that we
found out another way
the pair were instead working on several
related conjectures like you know you're
like taking a walk that you aim at the
seemingly very different and distant
destination but on the way you are
finally able to find you know some very
surprising hidden Beauty a key
breakthrough was the realization that a
method developed in the pursuit of one
conjecture could be used in a different
manner to solve Khan kalai the solution
utilized a mathematical object called a
cover you can think about a cover as
essentially a kind of necessary
condition or a witness to to the fact
that the network satisfied the property
Park and fam employed an algorithm to
sample subsets of a random graph to home
in on the cover in the end we verified
that cover is small in particular also
so that is exactly how we prove the
conjecture Park and fam's concise proof
of Khan kalai is expected to lead to new
breakthroughs this would allow us to get
a much better handle on complex
properties of networks and this is
suddenly used for in many applications
not just in in math or in probabilistic
combinatoric because the networks are
involved everywhere
[Music]
foreign
[Music]